[Music]
I'm Lily welcome to our cosmic power
shoes lily Reinhardt and Camilla Mendez
stun on these February covers of
Cosmopolitan magazine inside the mag the
leading ladies of Riverdale are getting
candid about sex love and Archie's music
[Music]
do you actually like Archie's music ah
listen everyone knows that I wouldn't
listen to it in my real life saying I
listen to it all the time fats are cheap
amazing and get this 21 year old Lily
says she's completely different from her
character Betty Cooper when it comes to
her sexuality quotes I'm very open
sexually I love to talk about sex it's
interesting and I want to see Betty have
a good time I also want to see her
explore her sexuality more she never
gets to she's always stressed poor girl
23 year olds Camila has this tip to
offer up when it comes to sex quote I
want to tell guys don't have sex at me
have sex with me I want them to
understand that it's so much better when
we are connected sure the starlet seemed
confident but Lily admits this quote one
big insecurity I had to get passed was
when the person I'm with has had more
sexual experiences that I have and has
been in love more than I have it's
mainly sexual though I find myself
thinking that they're comparing me to
their ex-lovers she says she knows that
silly adding besides they're with me for
a reason
you